y pasamos a las noticias de economía con
daniela blandón daniela bienvenida y hoy
es de ante amarillos y señora bueno y
comencemos en argentina para analizar el
caso de corrupción por el que se acusa a
la vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner pues maría clara comencemos
primero por hacer un pequeño repaso el
22 de agosto el fiscal argentino diego
lucían y pidió 12 años de prisión para
la vicepresidenta y también pidió
inhabilidad de por vida para ella para
ocupar cargos públicos en una de las
varias causas iniciadas en su contra
escuchamos las palabras del fiscal
estamos dejar en claro que se trata
probablemente de la mayor maniobra de
corrupción que se haya conocido en el
país en el cual los imputados mediante
una estricta división de roles
subvirtiendo las facultades legales que
te asignadas de manera sostenida el
tiempo
sustrajeron sistemáticamente fondos del
erario en provecho particular
adoptando todas las medidas que fueran
necesarias para efectuarla en
condiciones de impunidad es decir
desactivando para ello todos los
mecanismos de control ahora si vamos al
caso este es un caso conocido como
vialidad que inició en 2016 por la
adjudicación de 51 obras viales en la
sureña provincia de santa cruz esta es
la cuna del kirchnerismo bueno y qué
faltas dice la fiscalía que cometió la
vicepresidenta pues según la fiscalía en
el período comprendido entre 2013 y 2015
durante los gobiernos tanto de su
fallecido esposo néstor kirchner como de
cristina fernández el empresario lázaro
báez se quedó con el 85 por ciento de
esos contratos de los que veníamos
hablando no tenía vasta experiencia en
obras públicas de hecho era banquero
pero si era amigo personal de los
kirchner el ente acusador dice que el
fraude le habría costado unos mil
millones de dólares a la nación de hecho
una de sus peticiones es que se
decomisen bienes de al menos tres
implicados por 36,4 millones de dólares
cristina fernández es entonces acusada
de los delitos de administración
fraudulenta
asociación ilícita- ella se ha
desmarcado de los cargos ha denunciado
inclusive una persecución política en su
contra bueno ya propósito de estas
palabras el caso ha despertado amores y
odios en argentina cuenta en un más
claro que se y no solamente en argentina
también en el resto de américa latina
pero si nos vamos a este país pues ha
habido manifestaciones tanto en contra
como a su favor nuestro corresponsal en
buenos aires- natalio con soy ha estado
acompañando a los simpatizantes de
fernández a lo largo de toda esta semana
y esto nos contó en la noche del viernes
este es el barrio de recoleta uno de los
más elegantes de buenos aires donde hay
alguna de las propiedades más caras de
la capital argentina y aquí detrás mío
en ese edificio vive cristina fernández
de kirchner la vicepresidenta y ex
presidenta de la nación y desde el lunes
pasado a la noche estando una escena
algo inédita hay una suerte de vigilia
permanente de gente que la respalda de
militantes que están aquí decía desde el
lunes pasado cuando terminó la serie de
alegatos de la fiscalía en el en la
causa- vialidad en la que ella es una de
los imputados la fiscalía considera que
ella es parte de una asociación ilícita
para defraudar al estado y por eso la
acusado es un juicio que todavía sigue
adelante el tribunal está lejos todavía
de tomar una decisión definitiva pero
que necesitan aquí consideran que se
trata de una suerte de persecución
política y dicen estar aquí para
defenderla es pasar el día y la noche
cantando
en defensa de la vicepresidenta la
saludan cuando entran en la saludan
cuando salen y llegaron el lunes después
de que más temprano hubiera una pequeña
manifestación de gente en contra de la
vicepresidenta y desde entonces han
quedado instalados aquí esto es parte
además de una serie más grande de
manifestaciones a favor de la
vicepresidenta que han dado diferentes
actores políticos más de 500 intendentes
que son los alcaldes aquí el mismo
presidente de la nación y otras personas
cercanas del peronismo incluso el mismo
partido peronista ha dicho que está en
una suerte de estado de alerta
permanente por lo que puede ocurrir
aunque todavía realmente estamos muy
lejos de una definición en este juicio
de vialidad que ha causado esta suerte
de terremoto político en estos días en
argentina daniela ya propósito del caso
cuéntenos cuál es la percepción de
corrupción en argentina bueno
transparencia internacional elabora
anualmente un índice mundial de
percepción de corrupción una especie de
calificación en la que 0 equivale un
país muy corrupto y cien a uno muy
transparente en 2021 argentina se ubicó
en el puesto 96 en 380 países su
puntuación fue del 38 sobre 100 cayó 34
puntos y es el país en donde más baja de
la región transparencia internacional
destacó que en esta nación la injerencia
en el poder judicial por parte de las
autoridades políticas pone en peligro la
independencia del país y crea impresión
de impunidad gracias daniela por la
información económica y nosotros
seguimos con el debate